not not knuckles versus sonic right now
with our jacket that's right oh wow
that's right i know i'm such a company
man
same right exactly well listen
congratulations i mean it's hard to
believe that this is only your third
time ever reprising a role of course
there's ace ventura and dumb and dumber
what made you say yes a second time
around
i don't know i can't i can't serve the
same stale dinner you know what i mean
no i uh i i always felt like the time
for for now is to do something new you
know new now and uh you know if i spent
all my time doing a series of i could
have done several sequels with several
characters but i felt like that you know
life is too short i want to move on i
want to create i want to like annoy
people that are you know businessmen
that want to take advantage of me you
want to rock a big mustache the whole
nine yards i just want to keep changing
morphing
you know uh challenging people well
speaking of challenging people you told
us your grandson taught you how to floss
for this film where do your skills stand
now with the flossing have you held it
up i still do the dance but i don't do
the actual teeth thing right exactly
is there are there things that your
grandson is interested in these days
that now you're learning about and that
maybe you even like i haven't had the
talk yet
no
he's 12.
so it's a little early but he is very
critical of everything i do
oh yeah he rolls his eyes at everything
i do but i was going to wear it tonight
actually he left his tie at my house and
it was his favorite tie it was a a a
cat santa tie okay little kitty cats
with santa on them so i figured well
that's kind of nice he still has that
christmas all year long that beautiful
kind of innocence you know
jim you're set to be part of a netflix
special honoring your late friend bob
saget what does it mean to be a part of
that
uh well you know for me i was just going
down to the comedy store to pay tribute
to a friend you know and
it kind of turned into something else
and it was a really wonderful amazing
moment between a bunch of comics who you
know sit around at la and laugh at
really dark things and uh
you know uh and uh and that's the way we
have relief that's that's that's why
we're here we're here to uh you know
separate people from their egos
you know you listen you guys are the
people to do it you know yeah uh
yourself you're doing okay you know
there's still hope now as much as you
are still open to creating and doing new
things you know you did recently share
that you're ready to take a break from
acting can you elaborate on that comment
are we really not going to get any more
jim carrey roles i got to get out of
here before i slap someone
seriously
no um i just uh honestly i feel like
i feel like um there's so many things
because i've been so busy for so long
that i've important things that i've
ignored
like you know there's
25 years of mystery science theater i
have to catch up on
you know and uh and there's painting i
do paint you know i'm gonna be painting
i'm gonna be putting nfts out i'll
announce that on twitter soon where
you'll be able to find that
and uh that's kind of fun for me still
um other than that i'm uh i'm going to
strive for um
unexceptionalism
listen you have delivered nothing but
exceptionalism so i think you deserve
the break i want to be frighteningly
normal okay
yeah painting nothing going on
a whole lot of nothing well thanks
brendan
[Music]